the jurogan experience i tried watching
the
bourdain documentary but i just thought
i got too sad i couldn't do it and it
did it feel weird did you watch it
roadrunner oh yeah yeah did it feel
weird when you knew that the voice was
ai
sort of a recreation of his
words
it didn't feel weird to me because
honestly it was less than 45 seconds in
a two-hour film oh okay so
no it didn't feel weird i knew exactly
where one of the places
was that it was the ai but
the vast majority of that film is tony's
actual voice and i think that really got
lost in the discussion oh it certainly
did yeah i was under the impression that
the whole thing was that's how people
are they're so gross i always want to
find the one thing that's negative about
this yeah yeah it really bummed me out
because that was the that was the
dominant
conversation on opening weekend and it
really kind of took away for me from you
know the it's a beautiful film i was a
consulting producer so obviously i have
a dog in the fight and i want people to
love the film but i think it's
i think it's great it is really sad how
far into it did you get i just started
it and i shut it off
yeah
yeah
i just got too sad just
maybe it was my mood that day i just
wasn't i just wasn't ready to watch
something like that i was just like i
can't do this yeah i understand
you know i've been steeped in all things
tony for you know over a decade but
since he died i've been making these
books and working on the film and
talking about him and so i've kind of
got i think a layer of
numbness in a way but sometimes stuff
gets through when the first time i saw
the film i cried like a baby when i was
home by myself i was really glad to be
alone you know
there's always this feeling when someone
takes their own life
like if i could have just talked to them
like if i was there if i could have
talked to him
that's
you know i talked to david cho and he
had he had that same
he had that same take on it you know
just
you just don't know
you know you feel like
you [ __ ] something up like you feel
like
it's just it's there's no there's no
there's no
peace you know if you're always if i
think about him i i i
i just always think
like what a shame
what a shame
you know
like a guy who is so interesting and so
loved
you know to
i found out about it from uh maynard
keenan from tool do you know the story i
i listened to you uh
talked to uh tom papa right after uh
tony died so yeah
he made kind of a
joke right yeah jimmy was a funny guy
and he was joking around he said that
you know he knew that tony was really
into jiu jitsu and maynard really into
jiu-jitsu too and it's like we should
have a celebrity match
you know that would be awesome and he
was talking about it and then
he texted me and said i guess the
celebrity match is off
and i was like what does that mean like
i guess he has just assumed that i would
have already known about it but i was in
chicago and i just woken up
so then i googled it and i was just like
oh
yeah that's not a great way i mean
there's no good way to find out that
news but
that
sounds like a particularly painful way
to uh to hear it it was confusing you
know it's painful but it's like it's
it's almost like it's painful later
in the beginning it's just like
shock you're baffled
like how what
not there anymore like this person is
not there anymore like if i text him
it's not there yeah i have a phone that
i won't get rid of
because it has text messages from him
it's like
that i can always go back and look at
them yeah
yeah same i have i'll never get rid of
my last texts with him i mean it's
and what you were saying about you know
you just wish you could have done
something i mean believe me that is
that is a conversation i have had with
so many people and i think to myself
like if i had just been a little more
i don't know something if i had
if i had said something or if i had been
more supportive or you know i just i
knew he was in trouble that week but i
didn't
it never occurred to me that he would
take that action that he did and and and
the fact is he had a lot of people
around who were very close to him who
loved him uh and he had other people
that were offering to come
and and be with him because they knew he
was having a hard time that week and he
said no don't come
so it's why was that week so
particularly hard
he was
there was some stuff in the media with
uh with him and his girlfriend that was
you know not great uh you know he was
very very in love and uh i think there
was some i mean this i'm not saying
anything that isn't public record and
i'm always
hesitant to talk too much about about
all of that but it's you know it was
it's out there it was in the
uh italian press and maybe the french
press that uh that his girlfriend had
been maybe or maybe not with another guy
there were a lot of pictures that made
it look
not great
and i think that was really hard for him
um
and you know you'll see they talk about
it he it gets talked about in the film
it gets talked about in my book um you
know i think he was
he was deeply in love and i think he was
realizing that this relationship maybe
wasn't what he thought it was or that it
just i think he felt humiliated honestly
you know and i mean
that's a hard that's a hard thing
for a private person to
metabolize and then you know your
extremely public
person who has been extremely public
about this relationship i think it was a
lot for him to handle in that week
[Music]
yeah there's not much he can do when
that happens in terms of like talking to
a friend like words just don't work yeah
you know like they
you
don't
you're not going to absorb them
[Music]
yeah it's uh
you know it's
i don't know that someone i don't know
that a normal thing i don't know that a
normal reaction to romantic trouble is
to take your own life i don't you know
clearly there's you know there are
plenty of people who have trouble in
their relationships who stay alive
uh
you know he was a really complicated guy
he was a really
i think as as public as he was and as
much as he shared about the way that his
mind and his heart worked i think there
was a lot that he didn't share and i
think he was
more troubled and more lonely and sad
than i think any of us knew at the time
you know in the
intervening three years i've learned a
lot more about him and i thought i knew
him inside and out i was his assistant
for 10 years you know we wrote a book
together
i had done some traveling with him not
extensively but i did a handful of trips
over the years you know we were in
contact every day and
um
you know when i started to talk to
people after he died there was just a
lot a lot more to him a lot more to his
story
yeah whenever anybody
um recovers from a serious drug problem
but yet still parties
i was always like hmm how's he pulling
that off
like the first time i hung out with him
i knew that he had
gotten over the heroin thing
but i didn't quite realize how hard he
drank
i was like whoa
yeah
was that in montana when you guys no
that was later that was after i'd known
him for quite a while
i mean i think the first time i hung out
with him was in vegas
pretty sure
um it was when he was married to octavia
and
they were there for the ufc and i met
him backstage okay i was like wow
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify